it's never just about the protagonist
now i don't know about you but i feel
the anime that stand out completely on
the foundation of solely the
protagonists are few and far between
that's doubly true for a lot of action
shows for every cool protagonist you
have you have those mentors those rivals
those friends and whatnot who helped
carry the show for me the best action
slash battle titles are those that have
the side characters that get their time
to shine so today i'm going to be giving
the spotlight to these kinds of
characters here are my top 10 side
character fights in anime some are
amazing in the context of the story and
helps shed light on these characters in
more subtle ways while others are just
simply visual spectacles let's begin
[Music]
kenpachi always struck me as a captain
with presence his fight with ichigo and
insane bloodlust make him very memorable
the weakness of that kind of character
is that the character eventually stops
getting ample development becoming one
note with a lack of characterization now
that's not exactly the case for kenpachi
and while he's got many moments that
show his background and character one of
the most iconic ones at least in the
anime come in the form of battle how
appropriate kenpachi seems to be one of
those characters who have plot armor
unless they're facing the protagonist or
main antagonist so it's a breath of
fresh air to see kenpachi struggle in
this battle against the espada it's an
appropriate way to insert more of his
backstory and to show that he's got more
tricks up his sleeve even though
literally switching to swinging with two
hands feels so simple still for kampachi
fight this is the best one we have to
date
[Music]
number nine is katsura vs shokaku
a show that has some of the strongest
side characters it's just appropriate
for one of the best shown and anime out
there i can pick from so many fights but
i think it's about time we give katsura
some shine for this video and what a
journey it's been for katsura but in
case you need a reminder that this is
one badass we have his fight against
shokaku as proof this for me is
gatsura's main highlight in the entire
series with him returning to his
ingenious and badass ways in combat the
finish is also a good mix of sirius and
comical with the fight being decided
with a headbutt of all things then again
the battle has been decided before that
like gameparty's fight this one serves
both to establish gansura as a combatant
and add more depth to him as a character
it's these kind of fights that are the
best and i've grown to like and respect
katsura a lot more after this one
next is zorro versus killer
[Music]
who's your favorite one-piece side
character as far as i know a lot of
one-piece fans can't get enough of zorro
how can they get tired of him with him
being one of the coolest members of
luffy's squad that largely has to do
with how he gets the best looking fights
and the most awesome techniques and this
fight with killer ended up being a fight
to remember the battle does an excellent
job in showcasing his resourcefulness as
a fighter intertwined with his bloodlust
and hunger for the intensity of battle
all while giving us amazing modern
one-piece animation with the way things
were presented we got our feelings
dragged deep into this fight much like
gintama before it one piece does have a
knack of being funny or cartoony before
shifting into high gear and giving us
fights with presentation that you'd
expect from a ufo table show or
something like that sorrows still got a
lot of awesome fights but this one will
have to do for the list
before we move on to the next entry let
me ask you a question ever wonder what
it's like to play a mobile mmo while
enjoying all the graphical perks of a
console game our sponsors of this video
dragon raja's got you covered dragon
rodger is the fantasy rpg where you'll
lose yourself in the eye-popping beauty
of the world generated with ue4
technology it's also got a very in-depth
and innovative system that will allow
you to customize your character both in
appearance and in career and we're not
just talking playing character
generators here we're talking super
detailed customization system down to
the shape of your face they say the mmos
are an extension of our everyday lives
and the same holds true for dragon roger
thanks to its cutting-edge social
systems you can easily meet new friends
and form strong bonds with people or you
can choose to form groups with your real
world friends and have the time of your
lives this summer the team has prepared
a big summer season update that will
surely spice things up in a major way
i'm talking things like major gameplay
updates new items countless rewards and
gifts everywhere with an awesome update
looming now's the time to get into the
craze download dragon raja now by
following the links in the description
don't forget to check out their social
media as well for the latest news and
updates and speaking of ufo table we
have lancer versus assassin in our
seventh slot
animation quality and epic music
direction have long become staples of
ufo table productions give them the
budget of a theatrical production and
you get insane bouts like this one
granted i've often talked about other
heaven's feels fight like the rider vs
saber one from the third film so i
decided it's time to give lancer his
dues after all i feel he's a grossly
underrated character thanks to the memes
and always dying he still dies in this
one but at least he goes down with more
fight than we've ever seen before the
wild chase sees him give assassin all he
can throw and in a regular match lancer
would have easily gotten the win here
unfortunately he is lancer and he's up
against one of the driving forces for
the antagonist side so we know how that
goes still the showing he put up along
with ufo tables masterful work in
creating this fight for us to feast our
eyes on earned this moment a spot on my
list
at number six we have vector versus
berkoli
in isekai titles it's often the main
hero who gets all the shine in a large
part of sao this is proven true that's
none more evident than what war of
underworld's climax ended up amounting
to however in the same arc we do get to
see the integrity knights pull their
weight with the most iconic being their
leader berkoli its leader to leader as
berkoli fights dark emperor victor in
what was to a lot of people war of
underworld part 2's high point he finds
himself grossly outmatched but can
clutch a win against the dark emperor
himself by showing off the full power of
his super broken sword what brought this
fight up was the huge bump in art and
animation quality sao is great in the
presentation department and things went
up a whole notch for the wou fights this
being the most striking example of them
next is doppio vs risotto
[Music]
now this one's a doozy jojo's known for
its frankly insane fights and even the
side characters get to join in on the
fun too don't you get excited to know
what happens when you put some of the
side characters powers many which are
far more interesting on paper than the
ones carried by heroes against each
other here we have metallica versus king
crimson being wielded by risotto and
doppio respectively the fun thing about
this fight is that despite king
crimson's very fearsome reputation
doppio plays the underdog for the most
part of the encounter well it's just a
part of king crimson but still the
battle between risotto's iron
manipulation and one of the most
fearsome stands is a sight to behold a
third stand aerosmith ends up being the
deciding factor in the battle that was
sorely going in risotto's favor in the
end it's more of what you'd expect from
jojo fights a lot of stuff happening and
the anime team having the time of their
lives hamming it up
[Music]
[Music]
king bradley versus scar is rank number
four
scar's always been an enigma a great
rival character to follow and one who
never fails to make an impact that's why
it never came off as strange for me to
have him face off against probably the
most overpowered homunculus against king
bradley scott really had to work for the
win putting out all the stops and even
then it's barely even enough we've got a
lot of good exchanges with one of the
more notable parts of it from a
character perspective being sky using
alchemy to reconstruct mata breaking his
own code as an ish violin scar has gone
through some big character developments
as the series has gone on and along with
those moments comes this amazing fight
which feels like scar's last hurrah as a
fighter he had his last hurrah in one of
the most glorious ways possible taking
down wrath himself
the first slot in my top three belongs
to rain goku
[Music]
nobody
goku for such a short time that we got
to know him rengoku sure made the most
of it to give us a mental character to
remember he started the train arc being
a man of mystery and while he seems
quite nice and jovial it isn't until
later when we see how amazing he can be
sure overcoming nmu's dream is one thing
but i know we're all here for the argaza
fight an epic conclusion to a movie that
sees two top fighters trade blows with
such intensity that no one else can keep
up all done in the epic animation and
music the people have come to love demon
slayer 4 and more despite everything
ringoku still can't beat akaza but
there's still triumph in defeat moral
victories at that too dangerous sure
felt that way and i'm sure a lot of us
do too demon slayer does a good job in
crafting endearing characters in limited
space and thanks to his cool friendly
attitude as well as this visually
spectacular fight rengoku ends up being
proof of that
[Applause]
in second place obito versus kakashi
this feels like the culmination of a
storied rivalry that kind of runs
parallel to naruto and sasuke's
intertwined tale it barely has enough
screen time to compete with the latter
in terms of build up and legacy but i
knew from the moment their flashback was
shown that the two would somehow find
themselves at odds in combat i didn't
bite obito's supposed demise completely
and thank goodness i'm right because
this fight is insane we've seen how
powerful obito is as toby being the
catalyst for a lot of the key moments in
the series history and to see him
finally breaking out the toby disguise
and settling things with kakashi once
and for all was so hype also propping
the fight up is the fact that this is
kakashi's most important battle in the
entire series despite not having as much
on-screen history as the top fights in
naruto the actual fight in anticipation
more than made up for it as we're
treated to two blitzing their way in
attempts to work around each other's
abilities
[Music]
finally the best signed character fight
i have is netero versus meruemon
this is a fight that a lot of people
remember hunter hunter for but is it a
hot take if i were to say that in terms
of a pure fight standpoint the show has
a lot of other candidates to take the
crown no that's not a shot of the fight
itself but there are other impressive
battles in this excellent shonen title
why is it number one and why did i
choose it for this list then because of
its thematic power meruem barely fights
back and as a battle it sure feels
relatively anticlimactic given the
people involved but i think that that's
the beauty of it it's what made the
fight feel original something that
hunter hunter does so well with its
track record in subverting shonen tropes
it also does a great job of building up
natero adding the dimension to his
character about wanting to fight strong
opponents or while he goes down in a
blaze of glory the fight itself is great
presentation wise as with most of the
remake hunter hunter but the best fights
i feel are the ones with emotional
stakes that help flesh out characters
and with that regard this is one of the
best examples out there making it my
number one side character fight in
shonen anime
so those are my top tip but i've still
got several fights and i'm considering
giving a shout out still i'm more
interested in hearing what you think
comments and feedback for this video are
always much appreciated and i'd love
nothing more than to see what your top
10 looks like as always you can reach
out and connect on social media as well
as checking out the channel and its
partner channel vinnie tube kai to find
more videos that might interest you
don't forget to check out our sponsors
game dragon roger links in the
description i hope you had fun watching
this video and i look forward to seeing
you again